Supergirl landing you're gonna do a
superhero landing wait for it
hey youtubers is Charlie so two big
marvel movies coming from different
Studios around the same time of the year
in 2018 Black Panther and Deadpool
surprisingly based on some of the
comments from Black Panther himself the
characters are very similar so this
going to be a breakdown so the pitch is
is that black panther like out of
chadwick boseman own mouth says that he
thinks he's something of an antihero
sort of like I'm paraphrasing him
I feel like although he's a superhero
he's a super antihero but not
necessarily as crazy as say like
Deadpool but in the same vein not a hero
don't call me a hero that was like at
the top of that movie after he saves the
girl from the pizza dude but I love the
idea that black pant like he's just
gonna have no time for anyone's
in his movie now if you don't know when
that movie's coming out just a quick
reminder it's coming out February Black
History Month very important of 2018
just a couple months before Avengers
infinity war so while like all of the
phase 3 movies are going to lead into
Avengers infinity war black panther is
like the last movie to lead into that so
whereas with Deadpool you just see like
a really terrible person who's trying to
do you know just an awful awful human
being who gets superpowers but he still
cares for the people around him like he
still cares about Vanessa he wants to
protect them but he doesn't have any
interest in being like the traditional
superhero like he doesn't want to be
Captain America
I feel like Captain America is like the
gold standard for what everybody would
call a here like a traditional hero in
the Marvel Universe so like Black
Panther for instance on the other side
of that coin also not interested in
being Captain America he has all this
pent-up aggression like a very angry
person and we only know a little bit
about him coming into civil war like we
know that Wakanda has been very
isolationist they reference all the
vibranium getting stolen which is
something that happened pre Avengers age
of Ultron because that's where Ultron
got all his vibranium from he bought it
off of Ulysses Klaw who said he had
acquired it at great personal cost when
he should like the tattoo that he'd been
branded by the wakandans so very clearly
something really terrible happened in
Black Panthers past we don't know
exactly how long he's been black panther
but think about how all the best Marvel
heroes that we've
seen so far create the circumstances
that lead to like their big battles with
villains either they create the villain
or they create the circumstances that
lead to the big conflict to their movie
so another big future king in the Marvel
Universe is Thor we've seen a lot more
of Thor than we have a black panther but
think about what's happening at the
beginning of that movie
Thor's more of a douchebag at the
beginning of that movie like he's
rolling in like oh my god look at me I'm
so awesome I'm so handsome
he's like the Ron Burgundy of the Marvel
Universe so Loki is just like god damn
it everybody loves him I'm just gonna
wipe that smug smile off his face so you
have to imagine that been happening for
a long time so that when he finds out
that he's secretly a frost giant it's
just like the straw that broke the
camel's back so that's also kind of
happening in Black Panther but obviously
Black Panther isn't a douchebag like he
doesn't come off that way in civil war
he just comes off as someone who's very
short just does not have time for anyone
like he is a funny character but most of
the humor flows out of like the
situations that he's in like when
Hawkeye introduces himself in the middle
of the battle like hey man I'm Hawkeye
and he's just like I don't I don't care
it's just hilarious watching him shut
Hawkeye down but Black Panther wasn't
telling a joke like he wasn't trying to
be funny he was just like I don't give a
what we've learned is is the
Michael d Jordan's gonna be playing one
of the big villains of the film kill
monger
so obviously definitely not like the
Loki character in the relationship isn't
quite the same thing like he's not an
adopted son he was never meant to be
king but he has this very strong idea of
protecting his home he is from Wakanda
but what happened is is Ulysses Klaw
came in with his gang in force kill
mongers family to help him so when the
wakandans caked ulysses klaw out they
also kicked out kill mark they exiled
him from his homeland so kill monger
seeking revenge went to America went to
MIT got this amazing education you know
became this powerful person in his own
right and was determined to come back
and make Wakanda great again so he's
going to get rid of Black Panther and
return them to their isolationist roots
so think about what was happening in
civil war before King Takako was
assassinated he was basically opening up
the borders of Wakanda saying we can't
be isolationist anymore we went through
this tear
or deal where a bunch of our vibranium
was stolen and used as a weapon of mass
destruction so we have to become more
diplomatic kill mongers the person who's
grown up hating him in seeks revenge
wants to return Wakanda to its
isolationist roots kick the rest of the
world out because the rest of the world
is terrible
so already he kind of sounds like a
couple real world politicians just be
really terrible people who given the
chance would just sink Wakanda like the
Titanic it would just be terrible for
that nation but black panther you know
being the hero of the movie and calling
himself an antihero obviously wants to
stop that from happening but like
deadpool bringing back around a Deadpool
you know even though they want to get
rid of a really bad person doesn't mean
that they're interested in being this
shining example of heroism for the rest
of the world like Captain America is but
let me know in the comments what do you
think that chadwick boseman means when
he says that Black Panther is an MCU
super antihero
I just feel like you know he's gonna get
rid of the villains in his movie like
he's gonna kick him out of Wakanda but
he's not interested in being everybody's
best friend like he's look I'm gonna do
the right thing but not because I want
everybody to see me doing the right
thing just because I really hate the
alternative so it's kind of the same
thing with Deadpool where he's like look
I'm very self-interested I'm a very
selfish person I'm not nice I literally
kill people for money but most of the
people that I kill are really bad people
so quick reminder just because if we're
talking about Black Panther Deadpool 2
does not have an official release date
yet but they start shooting the movie
early next year usually it takes about a
year to turnaround a movie in
post-production maybe a little bit
faster if there's not too many special
effects but I feel like what their goal
is going to be if they can't get the
movie out by the end of 2017 which I
don't think that they will is that
they'll release it just like they did
the first Deadpool movie at the
beginning of the you know like around
Valentine's Day of 2018 which means it's
going to come out right around Black
Panther so I feel like February 2018 is
just going to be an awesome month for
lovers and for Marvel anti-heroes you
guys can let me know in the comments
though when do you think the Deadpool 2
is actually going to drop do you think
it'll take them about a year to finish
movie and they'll try to release it
around Valentine's Day of 2018 the same
way they did with the first movie it
makes sense that they would try to drop
the movie relatively early in the year
just because it wouldn't have quite as
much competition from the other really
big superhero movies like they're not
going to release it right next to
guardians of the galaxy - but I feel
like even though the characters are both
anti-heroes the movie is going to be so
different that there's not going to be
any competition like you're like oh my
god I gotta go see Black Panther oh my
god I gotta go see Deadpool - so it's
not really gonna be an issue but why you
guys think about that I'll say
congratulations to this week's Captain
America giveaway winner Rob Ruiz you win
a copy of the Civil War blu-ray be sure
to private message me on the back end of
my channel so I can get your contact
details and there is a new round that
starts now all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber leave a comment on
this video so I'll be posting some DC
next so that should post later tonight
while you guys wait for that to post you
can click here for my Avengers infinity
War teaser Thanos has officially left
the chit like purple man has left the
chair and you can click here to learn
all about Deadpool - thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight